à cette période de l'année la promenade
des anglais est rempli de touristes
cette fois ce sont des manifestants
antiracistes qui arpentent ce lieu
emblématique de la ville
le préfet des alpes-maritimes avait
pourtant interdit tout rassemblement en
raison de l'épidémie de covin 19 après
un accord avec les forces de l'ordre
présentes sur place
les participants ont été autorisées à
défiler
je tiens à remercier la police vraiment
pour nous avoir donné leur accord
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont fait ça
mais je pense que c'est parce qu'on a
bien insisté sur le fait qu'on veut
diffuser un message de paix entre quoi
tu vas aller voir quelques police est
alors je leur ai serré la main ça me
fait très plaisir et encore une fois on
n'est certainement pas contre la police
j'espère que la foule a bien compris ça
on est contre les violences policières
on ne peut pas de policier raciste mais
merci vraiment aux policiers pour le
travail qu'ils font c'est énorme
merci aux policiers de l'ombre à 6tu pas
question pour les manifestants de
prendre des risques
équipés de masques ils ont marché
pacifiquement contre les violences
policières en france ou aux états unis
mais aussi contre le racisme et des
préjugés
il faut militer en fait c'est la seule
chose qui à faire et on l'a bien vu aux
etats-unis c'est parce qu'il ya eu tous
ces manifestations qu'au final les
meurtriers qui ont tué georges floyd ont
pu être arrêté et donc c'est en poussant
en poussant en poussant dans les
manifestations que on voit que ça marche
donc en tant qu on puisse en tant que
personnes blanches c'est la seule chose
que je peux faire cesser les définitions
données de dire aux gens qu'il faut pas
être raciste qu'au bout d'un moment et
manifester quoi c'est tout ce qu'il a à
faire en fait ça me tient à coeur parce
que ça fait depuis très longtemps que je
trouve que mon peuple
les noirs en référence souffre plus
beaucoup trop depuis des siècles souffre
des matelas des malveillances policière
du racisme ou comment on voit maintenant
georges clyde adama traoré à paris et
encore plein d'autres qu'on ne citera
pas les noms parce qu'il y en a eu des
victimes
donc plutôt que de rester derrière mon
écran et de poster des trucs qui ne sert
strictement à rien j'ai décidé qu'il
était temps de passer à l'action
a nice comme dans de nombreuses villes
de france la journée de samedi était
placée sous le signe des luttes contre
les inégalités
[Musique]